no tread um burns in the West morons
Bernie Sanders heads over to Fox News
and Nancy Pelosi struggles with the
fresh faces I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show man yesterday was a
rough news day I mean watching Notre
dumb burn obviously the place has
incredible historical significance when
we get to all of that in just one second
but first let's talk about your business
hiring is challenging but there's one
place where you can go that hiring is
simple fast and smart it's a place where
growing businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiters
calm slash daily wire zip recruiter
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and them invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that's
zip recruiter comm slash at Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash at daily wear
zip recruiters indeed the smartest way
to hire there's a reason we use a zip
recruiter over here at the daily wire
and you can check them out right now for
free at zip recruiter comm slash up
daily wear when you do you get the best
employees and it helps you filter out
all the bad resumes so check them out
zip recruiter comm slash at daily wire
that zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
so obviously the big news of the day
yesterday was the burning down of most
of Notre Dom's Cathedral they're the
outer structure was indeed saved
according to French fire services Sky
News says flames broke out at the 12th
century building on Monday evening
quickly devastating the spire and roof
and sending plumes of smoke into the sky
one fire was serious firefighter was
seriously injured local media say police
were treating the blaze as an accident
French president Emmanuel macron said he
was so sad tonight to see this part of
us all burn and declared a national
emergency speaking from the scene in
Paris he expressed sympathy with
Catholics around the world following the
terrible tragedy but added that the
worst had been avoided and then he vowed
to launch an international fundraising
campaign apparently wealthy investors
have already pledged to give a hundred
million euros for the rebuilding of
I'm Frances interior minister originally
warned that the 400 firefighters
scrambled to the scene would not be
enough to save the Cathedral but a
junior minister from the department
later said they were more optimistic
that the cathedral itself could be
spared a French firefighter official
confirmed that Notre Dom structure and
two towers had indeed been saved from
total destruction
Prime Minister Theresa May said her
thoughts are with the people of France
tonight and with the emergency services
who are fighting the terrible blaze the
video of it was just astonishing and
shocking the area where the spire once
was was still burning with sparks
falling from the cathedral vaulted
ceiling as of Monday night people
outside were singing hymns and gasping
as they watched much of the much of the
Cathedral burned to the ground the Paris
mayor and Hidalgo urged the public to
respect the security perimeter around
the cathedral while firefighters tackled
the terrible blaze added that the area's
close to the scene were evacuated rich
Lowry over at National Review has a good
review about what exactly
notre dominant means says Notre Dom
stands for so many qualities that we now
lack patience and staying power the
cultivation of beauty a deep religious
faith the cultural confidence and
ambition to build a timeless monument of
our civilization that the collapse of
its spire was almost too much to bear
the great novelist Victor Hugo who did
so much revived interest in the
Cathedral when it was in disrepair in
the 19th century wrote how quote every
surface every stone of this venerable
pile is a page of the history not only
of the country but of science and art it
was the work of generations completed
across three centuries in a triumph over
considerable architectural and
logistical challenges it arose at the
original site of a pagan temple
thousands of tons of stone had to be
transported from outside Paris one ox
cart or barge at a time to achieve its
soaring height and hold up its ceiling
and walls it relied on the architectural
innovations of the rib vault and the
flying buttress France built 80
cathedrals and 500 large churches around
across this period says rich Lowry
there's only one at notre Tom of Paris a
gothic jewel whose towers prior to the
advent of the Eiffel Tower were the
tallest structure in the city it is or
one hates to think was adorned by what
are culturally significant artifacts in
their own right the statuary meant to
illustrate the story of the Bible and to
all worshippers who couldn't read the
stained glass windows that took
ingenuity to embed in stone walls and
are themselves artistic marvels the
organ with more than eight thousand
pipes the bells with their own names
including the largest the masterpiece of
manual dating back to the 15th century
and recast
1681 not to mention the religious relics
that means so much to the Catholic face
faithful it has been the site of
countless processions and services to
petition and thank God on behalf of the
French nation it is where illustrious
marriages and funerals occurred where
Napoleon crowned himself Emperor where
Charles de Gaulle attended a mass to
celebrate the liberation of Paris in
1944 rifle fire echoing outside it
survived the rampages of iconoclastic
huger knots in the 16th century the
depredation of radicals during the
French Revolution into the 18th century
they transformed it into a shrine to the
cult of reason used it as a warehouse
and wanted to melt down the bells and
incidental damage during two world wars
in the 20th century all the while at
accumulated layers in history and
meaning it's a great advocate hugo
author of the famous hunchback of notre
dame wrote of how the greatest
productions of architecture are not so
much the work of individuals as of a
community are rather the offspring of a
nation's labor than the outcome of
individual genius that a positive a
whole people the heaped-up treasure of
centuries the residual left by
successive evaporations of human society
in a word a species of formations each
wave of time leaves its coating of Lumia
alluvium each race deposits his layers
on the monuments each individual
contributes his stone to it and that of
course is exactly right is amazing
yesterday I tweeted something out that I
thought frankly was was really
uncontroversial I tweeted out that no
trade on was a was a totem to Western
civilization and of Western civilization
and people got very upset with this
particularly a lot of folks on the Left
were very upset with this I tweeted out
if we wish to uphold the beauty and
profundity of the notre-dame Cathedral
that means Rifa millyar izing ourselves
with the philosophy and religious
principles that built it that means
reefa miliary familiarizing ourselves
with the precepts of catholicism with
western history with what catholicism
was with how it contributed to the west
and all of this stuff seems deeply
important to me this became very
controversial a lot of folks on the Left
were very upset with me for suggesting
this they said why can't we just
appreciate it just as a piece of art you
can appreciate it however you want but
if you want to know why so many people
in the West were deeply affected by the
burning of notre dom it wasn't just
because it was iconic it's because notre
dam holds deeper meaning because it is a
totem of a chain of history that
culminates in the modern West that's why
I know turnout means something different
then just
any building anywhere on earth burning
the Natasha Mahal burning for example
should be of course a phenomenal tragedy
but would not have quite the same
resonance in the Western mind as
notre-dame burning of course now you can
see the sort of the sort of anodyne
version of mourning for the cathedral
from Ilhan omar who of course is no big
fan of western civilization maybe she
said so she is americo's founded on
slavery and genocide I can only assume
she means that the rest of the West was
as well she tweeted out art and
architecture have a unique ability to
help us connect across our differences
and bring people together in important
ways thinking of the people of Paris and
praying for every first responder trying
to save this wonder again it's fine to
look at notre nom is just art and
architecture but it has deeper resonance
than that and that was the point that I
was making is that the deeper resonance
of notre dom is about the faith that
inspired notre dom and listen this is
coming from a jew this is coming for an
orthodox jew notre dom apparently had
certain statues that are anti-semitic in
nature talking about the supersession of
the Catholic Church over Jews in the
past that's important to remember it's
also important to remember then no-trade
nom is again a historical monument to
the chain of history of which we are a
part I wrote an entire book about this
my book the right side of history talks
about this chain of history the
judeo-christian history of the West and
how Judaism and Christianity combined
with Greek reason in play an intention
created the world in which we live I
want to read you a section from the book
talking about the period during which
notre dam was built notre dam of course
was built during the 12th and 13th
centuries it took a couple of centuries
to complete which in and of itself is an
amazing testament to the human mind and
to the power of the eternal to inspire
the human mind because after all why
plant a tree if you're not going to get
to sit in its shade why build a building
if you know that you're not going to get
to complete it because our task is not
to complete the building our task is to
join in the building of that structure
in the first place here's what I talk
about in my book with regards to this
period in Western history from the fall
of Rome through the 12th century
Christianity would spread from its base
in the Italian peninsula to the British
Isles France Germany and eventually the
Nordic countries as well well Augustine
had posited a great divide between the
City of God and the City of Man the
Catholic Church was quite active in the
city of Man the church received tithes
from Christians the continent / had its
own ecclesiastical courts by the 10th
century
the church was the single largest
landowner in Western Europe Kings found
their legitimacy through the conduit of
the church and battled with the church
to expand their own power Holy Roman
Emperor Henry the fourth walked barefoot
in the snow to earn back the approval of
Pope Gregory the seventh Henry ii of
england 11:33 to 1189 had himself
flogged in order to win back the
approval of his christian population
after accidentally ordering the death of
Archbishop Thomas Becket popular history
maintains that this period represents
the dark ages but that's simply
inaccurate progress continued as
Christianity spread the monastic system
centralized learning and monasteries
where priests and nuns devoted
themselves to ascetic pursuit of divine
understanding in educational terms this
devotion revolves around Scripture the
Benedictine monks for example lived
under the rules created by st.
Benedictine for 82 547 a set of orders
regarding the hierarchy of monasteries
the behavior by which to abide and the
requirements of work the arts thrived in
the monastic system manuscripts were
preserved by monks devoted to writing
new copies and beautifying them in the
monastic system the liberal arts taught
by the Greeks and the Romans as
championed by Cicero and Seneca among
others survived albeit in spiritual eyes
form Augustine himself despite his
distaste for paganism suggested that the
liberal arts education could be hijacked
for service to God Augustine likens such
cultural appropriation to the Jews
taking Egyptian gold during the biblical
Exodus these liberal arts were
categorized by the philosopher
Boethius into the famous Quadra varium
music arithmetic geometry and astronomy
and Trivium grammar rhetoric and logic
meanwhile the Middle Ages saw
technological revolution in agriculture
the rise of commerce the institution of
new forms of art ranging from polyphonic
music
to Gothic architecture notre da would be
a perfect example of Gothic architecture
it also saw new developments in the art
of war with technological developments
that would allow the West to defeat its
enemies in the course of coming
centuries while many history historians
doubt the power of Islamic civilizations
during this time period an Islamic
civilization did thrive on the Arabian
Peninsula particularly when Islamic
civilization came up against Western
civilization at the Battle of Tours is
Lama courses were soundly defeated by
the eighth century Christian leaders
were crusading against enslavement
except notably for the enslavement of
Muslim war captives monasteries were
engaging in proto capitalism as well
furthermore the Catholic Church was
responsible for learning and teaching
virtually all literacy
bring from monasteries still the modern
world could not have been created under
these circumstances would I write my
book faith provided individual moral
purpose faith provided collective moral
purpose but while individual capacity
was bolstered by the doctrinal belief in
free will and the value of work reason
had been made secondary to faith while
collective capacity was bolstered by the
presence of a strong social fabric the
all-encompassing power of the Catholic
Church and the rule of monarchs meant
that individual choice was heavily
circumscribed even education had been
radically reoriented toward the church
all true knowledge lay in the Bible the
liberal arts were only useful so far as
they bolstered the biblical story for
science and democracy to take hold in
the West reason would have to be
elevated once more in a second I'm going
to explain how the reintroduction of
reason did happen in the West and within
the Catholic Church again reorienting
ourselves to this history means that
notre dom means so much more to us
because we look at it and it means
something beyond just a beautiful
building against that in just one second
first when the founders crafted the
Constitution the first thing they did
was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by their government the
second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
you know how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility and
building rifles is no different Bravo
company manufacturing was started in a
garage by a Marine veteran
more than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment and
they assume that every rifle leaving
their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier oversees every component of a
BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans to a life-saving standard
CCM feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that will not
fail the user when it's not just a paper
target but someone god forbid coming to
do you harm BCM works with leading
instructors of marksmanship from top
levels of America's Special Ops forces
who can teach the skills necessary to
defend yourself your family or others to
learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm that's Bravo Company
MFG comm if you need more convincing you
can find out even more about them at
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
amazing company I know the people
run it it is a great company go check
them out right now at bravo company MFG
comm so we're talking about the history
of Western civilization and where
Catholicism learn autre DOM
fits into that history because it means
more to us when we watch that building
burn than just a building burning so
I've been talking about the dominance of
the Catholic Church and the
reintroduction of reason to balance out
the the faith orientation of Catholicism
that process began I write in my book
the right side of history with the
reintroduction of Greek reasons to the
West in the 11th century Christianity
comfortable now in its dominance could
afford more exploratory thinking when it
came to second learning this bred a new
movement called scholasticism and that
movement encouraged Christians to extend
the provenance of God's dominance over
all of the areas of human knowledge
scholasticism would open the door for a
renewed investigation into the unity
between God and his created universe and
between faith and reason leading a
Scholastic hue of saint-victor 1096 to
11:41 famously said learn everything
later you will see that nothing is
superfluous he followed through on his
own injunction by attempting to write a
book that covered the gamut of human
knowledge known as a Summa scholasticism
became the dominant philosophy of the
church the church launched a program of
support for universities the University
of Paris also known as the Sorbonne the
University of Bologna the University of
Oxford as Thomas woods jr. writes the
church provided special protection to
university students by offering them
what was known as benefit of clergy the
Pope's intervened on behalf of the
university on numerous occasions and
then the Christian world moved in to
Thomism under Thomas Aquinas so the
bottom line here and the reason that I'm
recounting this history is because if we
don't reorient ourselves to this history
why are these buildings important
they're just buildings after all sure
they're beautiful but they are more than
beautiful they're Testaments to an
ongoing battle between faith and reason
that has bred the West and that that
battle has had victims that battle has
had people who have suffered for sure
but that does not change the story of
the West we are part of that great river
of history and that's why when we see
something from our past burned to the
ground like that it's devastating to
everybody involved okay meanwhile
speaking of people who don't know their
history so Bernie Sanders has apparently
taken the lead in a new Emerson poll in
the Democratic 2020 race mayor Pete is
on the move as well he's up to 9% he's
getting all sore
glowing media attention right now and of
course people are very very excited
about the fact that he speaks French so
yesterday well Notre Dame was burning
they asked him for comment and then he
gave comments in French which is cool
John Kerry could do it as well so can
Melania Trump I guess but I guess that
that's innate for what it's worth in any
case Bernie Sanders has has taken the
temporary lead and people are concerned
in the Democratic Party that his win in
the nominating process will mean I guess
the end of the chances to stop Donald
Trump and this has led to the New York
Times actually writing a full piece
about it in which they talk about how
terrible it would be if it were to be
that that Bernie Sanders if you would
win the nomination
how terrible all of this would be so the
New York Times suggests that there is a
new group that is out there fighting
Bernie Sanders quote when lay adultery a
former Democratic Party official
addressed a closed-door gathering of
about 100 wealthy liberal donors in San
Francisco last month all it took was a
review of the 2020 primary Ruth rules to
throw a scare into them Democrats are
likely to go into their convention next
summer without having settled on a
presidential nominee says miss Daughtry
who ran her party's conventions in 2008
and 2016 the last two times the
nomination was contested and senator
Bernie Sanders is well positioned to be
one of the last candidates standing she
noted I think I freaked them out Dennis
Daughtry from kin appealed fundraisers
on the coast to the cloak rooms of
Washington mainstream Democrats are
increasingly worried that their efforts
to defeat President Trump in 2020 could
be complicated by Sanders in a political
scenario all too reminiscent of how a
Trump himself sees the Republican
nomination in 2016 well this is what I
have been saying here on the program for
months is that Bernie Sanders is in fact
well-positioned to do serious damage in
the Democratic primaries why well
because he's got somewhere between 25
and 30 percent of the vote and it is a
very solid 25 to 30 percent everybody
else is moving around Beto's been
bouncing around between 8 and 12 Biden
has been bouncing around anywhere
between 35 and 25 Bernie Sanders seems
incredibly stable and Joe Biden is gonna
get torn down as the front-runner and
everybody in the Democratic Party feels
the need to pay homage to Bernie Sanders
in much the same way that many in the
Republican Party felt the need to pay
homage to President Trump because Trump
was in fact this deeply popular figure
an extraordinarily famous to boot
Republicans basically ignored Trump
during the 2016 election cycle thinking
this can't last the guy's got to
collapse and when he collapses for sure
his support will go to me this was the
strategy above Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz
is why they ignored Trump and went after
each other
of course Trump lasted the test of time
and the other candidates did not you
could see very much the same thing here
happening with Bernie Sanders if you
attack Bernie the Bernie bros come after
you if you leave Bernie alone and you go
after Joe Biden and you try to
cannibalize his support then perhaps
you're able to pick up support in spite
of Bernie Sanders but that means that
Bernie Sanders is still standing and
this is freaking out the Democratic
bigwigs The New York Times reports how
some Democrats are beginning to ask do
they fort a 70-something candidate from
outside the party structure who is
immune to intimidation or incentive and
wield support from an unwavering base
without simply reinforcing his the
establishment is out to get me message
the same grievance that Trump used to
great effect stopping Sanders or at
least preventing a contentious
convention could prove difficult for
Democrats he has enormous financial
advantages he's already substantially
out raising his Democratic rivals he is
well-positioned to benefit from a
historically large field of candidates
that would splinter the vote and he'd
pick up a formidable number of Delegates
for the nomination because there are no
super-delegates
this time that prospect is not only
spooking establishment aligned Democrats
it's also creating tensions about what
if anything should be done to halt
Sanders there's a never Sanders movement
that apparently is cropping up among
Democrats some in the party still Harbor
anger over the 2016 race when he ran
against Hillary Clinton and his ongoing
resistance to becoming a Democrat when
his critics are chiefly motivated by a
fear that nominating an avowed socialist
would all but ensure President Trump a
second term David Brock who is a Clinton
ista hack he's the the founder of Media
Matters he says there's a growing
realization that Sanders could end up
winning this thing or certainly that he
stays in so long he damages the actual
winner he has had discussions with other
operatives about an anti Sanders
campaign he believes it should commence
sooner rather than later man the
bloodbath in this primary is going to be
amusing to watch from the right and
horrifying to watch if you were on the
Left RT Rybak the former Minneapolis
mayor who is vice chairman of the DNC in
2016 complained bitterly about the
party's tilt toward mrs. Clinton back
then warned that it would backfire of
his fellow mainstream Democrats start
with the idea they're gonna try to stop
somebody if the party fractures again or
if we even have anybody raising an
eyebrow
I'm not happy about this we're gonna
lose and they'll have this loss on their
hands so now the number Sanders movement
is getting pilloried by the pro Sanders
movement as people who will be
responsible if Trump wins re-election
all of this sounds very familiar
so not insignificant number of Democrats
in New York the the New York Times says
Mr Sanders his populist agenda is
exactly what the country needs and he
has proved his mettle the good news for
his foes that his polling is down
significantly in early nominating States
from 2016 he is viewed more negatively
among Democrats and many of his top
rivals he's already publicly vowed to
support the party's nominee if he falls
short but I'm not sure that matters if
you recall president Trump's negatives
were much higher than his opponents and
he cruised to the nomination on the back
of 35 to 40 percent support it started
off at 25 to 30 and then included 30 to
35 and by the end he was winning 35 to
40 percent in all of the major
nominating contests Sanders is already
sending blistering letters to his
enemies he sent a blistering letter to
the Center for American Progress which
is a Clinton Easter outfit accusing them
playing a destructive role in democratic
politics and being beholden to the
corporate money they receive he's also
trying to woo a lot of veteran party
strategists in places like Iowa Tad's
vine and Sanders his longtime strategist
he says if anybody thinks Bernie Sanders
is incapable of doing politics they
haven't seen him in Congress for 30
years know what we've seen is a guy who
actually hasn't gotten anything done but
he has maintained a spot and that's all
he really has to do so Democrats are
starting to get very very nervous very
nervous the matter of what to do about
Bernie and the larger imperative of
party unity has for example hovered over
a series of previously undisclosed
Democratic dinners in New York and
Washington organized by longtime party
financier Bernard Schwartz the
gatherings have included scores from the
moderate or since her left wing of the
party including Speaker Nancy Pelosi
Senator Chuck Schumer former Governor
Terry McAuliffe of Virginia P bhootish a
South Bend Indiana and the president of
the Center for American Progress
Neera tanden he did us a disservice in
the last election said mr. Schwartz a
longtime Clinton supporter who said he's
going to support Biden man if I had to
lay money right now I'd be hard-pressed
not to lay it on Bernie
considering the fanaticism of the people
who support him and the fact that
Democrats have no strategy for stopping
him in a second we'll show you the
Bernie Sanders went on Fox News last
night it was kind of interesting I'll
get to that in a second first it can be
a little frustrating especially if you
in a hurry or running late to find
yourself at a railway crossing waiting
for a train if the signals are going and
the trains not even there yet you could
feel a bit tempted to try and sneak
across the tracks do not do this ever
this is a stupid and bad idea
trains are often going a lot faster than
you expect them to be and they cannot
stop even if the engineer hits the
brakes right away it can take the train
over a mile to stop by that time well
you used to be your car is just a
crushed hunk of metal what used to be
you well then you got a problem point is
you can't know how quickly the train
will arrive the train can't stop even if
it sees you and the result is disaster
if the signals are on the train is on
its way
just remember one thing you can stop
trains cannot go check to make sure that
you please for God's sake don't run
train crossings my goodness it's just a
huge huge mistake it's amazing that
people think they can do this I mean
there are a number of deaths every year
from people who think that they can just
cross a train crossing in the middle of
a signal and that everything will be
hunky-dory that's not the way this works
Oh be smart stop because the trains
can't all right so Bernie Sanders was on
Fox News last night and well he was on
Fox News he basically laid out his
agenda which is you're gonna pay more
you're gonna spend a lot of money he's
asked about health care he says yeah my
agenda is you are going to B's with Bret
Baier and Martha McCallum he says yeah
you know you're gonna it'll cost more
money from your pocket you're you are
self-employed and you have got a husband
and two kids okay family of four you
know how much that family is paying
today for health care family
$28,000 see okay alright we're spending
$11,000 per person we are saying to that
family of four
you ain't gonna pay that 28,000 you're
not paying any more premiums you're not
paying any more co-payments you're not
paying any more deductibles how's that
28,000 you're not paying what does that
mean you're not gonna pay something of
course it does you're gonna pay more in
taxes okay you're gonna pay more in
taxes I love that he says it cost you
$28,000 your employer is paying that so
your employer is presumably not going to
pay for their health insurance anymore
and that means that your pay is
presumably going to be cut so your
top-line pay is going to be cut and then
you're gonna pay a lot more in taxes now
how much more in taxes a lot more in
taxes because the fact is that if you
want to pay more in taxes a nationalized
health care system is the best way to do
it there's a reason
at the Nordic countries I'll have tax
rates kicking in at anywhere in in
Norway it's 36% because of the giant oil
slush fund but in other places like
Denmark you've got top tax brackets
kicking in and like 50 to 60% to make
$60,000 a year that's what Sanders is
talking about it's funny that nobody
ever asked some Apollo up like what kind
of tax rates are you talking about and
at what level will they kick in nobody
asks him that because it would be
awkward for him to answer in any case
Sanders then continued he said listen
healthcare isn't free except that he
keeps promising everybody it's gonna be
freeze there's that it will drive up
taxes to pay for health care and not
just the wealthy will pay for the middle
class will also pay for every go so how
do you justify it and Martha what are
you not including in your discussion new
time I will tell you you're not got a
health insurance premiums health care is
not free you never suggest that we're
gonna March it was gonna be free for
everyone it's gonna be free at the point
of when you use it okay it's free at the
point when you use it that's idiotic
I mean that means it's not free so if I
pay a subscription fee to go to daily
wire it is then free when I click on
daily wire it is not free because I am
paying the subscription fee if I pay
taxes for something that makes it not
free I love that Bernie Sanders has been
getting away with this for a while
Martha McCallum calls him on this and
Sanders simply falls apart this wasn't
the only point and which Sanders fell
apart the most amusing point at which
Sanders fell apart
is he was asked okay you know Bernie you
make a lot of money and he does he's
been making about a million dollars a
year for the last several years and he
was asked specifically okay well you
know you could just pay extra taxes why
aren't you paying the extra taxes and
Bernie Sanders had no good answer to
this because of course if you are a
socialist and you want the government to
have more money you could do this to
show that you're a millionaire you did
make a million 2016-2017 you're right
that 561 and 2018 but your marginal tax
rate was 26% because of President
Trump's tax cut so why not say you know
I'm leading this revolution I'm not
going to take those
come dearie the I am I paid the taxes
that I go and by the way once you got
Donald Trump up here and asked him how
much he pays in taxes would you be
willing to pay fifty two percent on the
money that you made you can volunteer
you can send it you could volunteer to
we have a marker why don't you Jeff you
make more money than I cannot running
for Paris to me that Bernie Sanders is
saying to Martha McCallum why don't you
pay more in taxes why don't you um she
asked you because you say that everyone
should and she has not said that that's
the thing it's amazing I love the Bernie
Bros in the audience we're just glad
yeah Bernie saying Martha McCallum
should pay more taxes she's not running
for president she did not suggest a
wealth tax you did it is so he's running
away from the implications of his own
program because this is what all
socialists do in the end they sort of
like their lifestyle but they don't want
and they don't want to sacrifice it but
they do want to seem as though they care
a lot about government expenditures and
tax rates yeah there's the voluntary
minimum is what you pay when you pay
taxes that is your your the minimum that
you pay or the government comes and gets
you you can always sign a check for more
Bernie Sanders is not doing that Bernie
Sanders is incredibly radical he made
that clear last night he was talking
about abortion he says he suggested that
aborting babies until birth would be a
worthwhile goal and then he suggested it
was sexism to believe otherwise do you
believe that a woman should be able to
terminate a pregnancy up until the
moment of birth look I think that that
happens very very rarely and I think
this is being made into a political
issue
so I think it's rare it's being made
into a political issue but at the end of
the day I believe that the decision over
abortion belongs to a woman and a
physician not the federal government not
the state government it's being made
into a political issue now it was funny
a lot of the commentators yesterday
we're noting Wow look how on Fox News
people are cheering for Bernie yeah who
do you think shows up to a burning
townhall you mentioned right winger to
show up to a Bernie Town Hall he's done
for Bernie fans so listen it was very
smart of Bernie to appear on Fox News it
made him look good it made him look as
though he was willing to take hard
questions from people outside his own
party which apparently nobody else in
his party is willing to do and Bernie's
populism does have some crossover with
trumpian populism it does and this is
how you end up with a situation in which
Bret Baier pulled the audience on
Medicare for all and people cheered and
Meteor like oh my god people in a Fox
News audience cheering for Bernie yeah
there Bernie fans that's why they're
there they're there because they like
Bernie who shows up to a burning
townhall unless you like him it has
Republicans independents Democratic
socialists conservatives I want to ask
the audience a question if you could
raise your hand here a show of hands of
how many people get their insurance from
work private insurance right now how
many get it from private insurance okay
now of those how many are willing to
transition to what the senator says a
government-run system raucous applause
from the same people who are applauding
all night and again it was very funny to
watch disingenuous people in the media
saying look at that Fox News audience
cheering Bernie
now he's popular among Fox News audio
yeah sure I'm sure that's what happened
right there I'll show you the rest of
Bernie Sanders is radical pitch he has
no actual on-the-ground hard policy
suggestions that are anywhere close to
reasonable but that's not what Democrats
are looking for these days we'll get to
that in just one second first no one
really has time to go to the post office
you're busy who's got time for all that
traffic parking lugging all your mail in
packages it's a real hassle
that's why you need stamps comet is one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
get even at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office right
your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in the mailbox it's that
simple with stamps comm you get five
cents off every first class stamp and up
to 40% off Priority Mail not to mention
it's a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters stamps comm is
a no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses already use stamps comm right
now my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
comm click on that microphone at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm enter Shapiro once again
stamps comm and answer Shapiro for that
special deal already
we're gonna get to more Bernie Sanders
plus the Democrats in Congress running
scared from their own base we get to all
that in just one second first you have
to go over to daily wire comm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe to daily wire comm when you do
you get the rest of this show live you
get two additional hours of this show
every afternoon we have so much good
stuff coming up for you this afternoon
guests like Bishop Bishop Robert Barron
who's gonna be showing up to discuss the
history of Notre Dom we're gonna be
having on Daniel Hannan the EU Member of
Parliament from Britain it's he's gonna
discuss Western civilization as well as
brexit so we have lots of good stuff
that comes up for you every afternoon
two hours he can't get unless you
subscribe go check that out plus you can
ask me questions in the mailbag it means
get our Sundays special a day early on
Saturday all sorts of amazing stuff
happening over at Daily wire and with
your annual subscription you get this
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist years how to hold
tumblr look upon it and weep before you
have it not but you could all you have
to do is subscribe for 99 bucks a year
ago check that out right now also
subscribe at YouTube in iTunes please
leave us a review it always helps us we
have the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
Haworth while pointing out at this point
that bernie sanders has indeed released
his tax returns and what they show is
that he has not given an extraordinary
amount of charity total and and that's
nothing new many Democrats do not give
an enormous amount of charity the dirty
little secret about charity is that as
charitable as Democrats pretend to be
when they are seizing the money from
your pocket it is Republicans who are
giving the vast majority of charity on a
per capita basis it's really it's really
astonishing so Bernie Sanders apparently
gave something like ten thousand dollars
the first year that he made a million
bucks
he gave like ten grand the second year
he gave something like thirty six grand
which is not too bad but this is not
supremely shocking apparently according
to the Washington Post Bernie Sanders
and his wife gave $19,000 to charity of
an out of an income of five hundred
sixty six thousand dollars last year or
three point four percent Kamala Harris
released fifteen years of her tax
returns on Sunday she and her husband
earned one point nine million dollars
last year they gave twenty seven grand
to charity one point four percent and
she gave no charity at all during her
first three years as California's
Attorney General senator Amy Klobuchar
of Minnesota and her husband donated
about six thousand dollars sixty six
hundred bucks of their three hundred
forty thousand dollar income to charity
last year's about two percent Kirsten
Gillibrand made 215 grand last year and
gave thirty seven hundred bucks to
charity the most generous was senator
Elizabeth Warren she about fifty
thousand dollars last year of their nine
hundred and six thousand dollar income
jay Inslee and his wife who recently
released twelve years of returns they
earned an income of two hundred and
three thousand dollars in 2018 and gave
about eight grand to charity now who
exactly has been extremely charitable
well Mitt Romney was extremely
charitable in 2012 when he finally
released his tax returns it showed that
he and his wife had given away four
million dollars out of the thirteen
point seven million dollars they took in
during the previous near a year almost
thirty percent of what they earned that
year they gave away in charity by the
way speaking of charitable people Barack
and Michelle Obama gave away twenty two
percent of their income to charity in
2011 they donated one hundred and
seventy two grand out of seven hundred
ninety grand you know who was
particularly stingy Joe and Joe Biden
they gave one point five percent of
their income to charity about fifty five
hundred bucks at a three hundred seventy
nine thousand dollars and in 2008
you'll remember that Joe Biden released
in ten years over the past ten years he
had given over ten years 37 hundred
bucks to charity an average of three
hundred sixty nine dollars a year so
really ramping up that spending it's
always fun to it is always fun to see
how much money Democrats actually give
to charity as opposed to the supposed
charitable mindset that they employ and
he saw that again when you see Bernie
Sanders scoffing and paying extra taxes
and suggesting that Martha McCallum
should because she's rich too and then
the Bernie bros idiotic lis cheering
along yay pretty amazing Bernie Sanders
by the way is as radical as radical
against it and most of his plans don't
have any on the ground actual teeth to
them because they're never going to be
implemented he has to get all this stuff
from Congress so for example Sanders was
asked about the situation along the
border and he suggested we should build
housing along the border for illegals
but the Democratic Party just rejected
funding for that stuff they need to go
somewhere because they're in that Asylum
what about building where would you put
them what about building proper
facilities for them right now we're
right on the water right on the border
at the same border should have more
facilities in their states but sanctuary
cities which have said they're also into
accepting people should not take now
this is a political act political
decision okay it's a but it's it's a
political decision it's not a spending
decision except the Democrats have not
provided the funding Trump has been
asking for billions of dollars in
funding so that he can increase the
number of beds this was the specific
immigration fight that just took place
Trump said we need more money for beds
on the border Democrats including Bernie
Sanders said no and then Bernie Sanders
is pitching let's build more housing
along the border for illegal immigrants
I mean he's just he's incoherent the
fact that he is leading is a result of
these stupid radicalism of a segment of
the Democratic base that has no real
relationship with reality and that's the
funniest part about all of this is that
there are leaders in the Democratic
Party looking at this askance and going
this is insane I mean Bernie Sanders by
the way it is worth noting he's a
radical on foreign policy too he said
that ohana Omar was not anti-semitic why
she's just anti-israel never mind she
hasn't
critiqued any of Israel's policies she
has just suggested that Israel
hypnotized the world that pro-israel
Jewish money was behind American support
of Israel and she suggested dual loyalty
of people who support Israel but
according to Bernie Sanders that's just
a critique of Israel it's not
anti-semitic to be critical of a
right-wing government in Israel okay
that is not anti-semitic however you
know it is also not anti Islamic
opposing Ilhan Omar's radicalism that's
not anti Islamic Bernie Sanders well all
of this is handing a very large club to
President Trump to wield against the
Democrats and they know it president
Trump yesterday on the campaign trail he
said listen socialism you know what that
is that's a method to get to the
poorhouse the numbers of blue-collar
jobs have recently grown the fastest
rate in more than 31 years so that's you
know what we're talking about they can
talk all they want about socialism all
socialism is is a method into the
poorhouse you know socialism is not so
easy to beat when an economy is really
doing well like ours we'll probably have
the best to cut it we may have the best
economy we've ever had okay he is right
about all of that he's also right that
socialism in the end is going to be
rejected by the American people how do
we know this because even top Democrats
recognize this so Nancy Pelosi has been
having a very very difficult time here
because she knows that her own base
loves the radical talk but very few of
them actually want the policy so she has
been desperately attempting to fend off
all of the radicals inside her own party
this is why she speaks disparagingly
about members of her own party this is
why in an interview yesterday with
lesley stahl on 60 minutes she suggested
that there were just five there there
were five radicals in the Democratic
Party she was she specifically said that
AOC Ilhan Omar Rasheed asleep that she
said that those like five people and
then when she was asked well they're the
progressives aren't they shouldn't know
I'm the progressive right now there's a
battle for the soul of the Democratic
Party are they going to be Nancy Pelosi
Chuck Schumer progressives or are they
going to be open radicals like Bernie
Sanders aoc ohan Omar and that elk so
here's Nancy Pelosi yesterday rejecting
socialism saying listen I'm not in favor
of socialism Medicare for all
not only being pushed by some members of
your caucus but also some of the
presidential candidates and it is
allowing the president to say you're all
socialists do you know that when we did
met when Medicare was done by the
Congress at the time under Lyndon
Johnson Ronald Reagan said Medicare will
lead us to a socialist dictatorship this
is an ongoing theme of the Republicans
however I do reject socialism as a
economic system if people have that view
that's their view that is not the view
of the Democratic Party Wow well she's
gonna have to fend off people like aoc
who is in fact a socialist she's a
member of the Democratic socialists of
America and that group explicitly says
that they reject the profit motive so
Nancy Pelosi is gonna have to battle
that off and she's not gonna have a lot
of success in doing that at the same
time that she's hosting people like
Jeremy Corbyn yesterday Pelosi and
Corbin got together to apparently
discuss myriad issues not including
anti-semitism it is pretty astonishing
she apparently said that she discussed
with Jeremy Corbyn anti-semitism during
her UK trip she said she had a candid
discussion she said please have a candid
discussion with Jeremy Corbyn today
about the direction of brexit Northern
Ireland NATO acting boldly on climate
protecting human rights and the
necessity of forcefully confronting
anti-semitism and Islamophobia yeah I'm
sure that went great
I'm sure Nancy Pelosi had some very
harsh words for Jeremy Corbyn
considering how few harsh words she has
had for Rashidah Talib and Ilhan Omar
open anti-semites in her own caucus so
Nancy Pelosi want to both ways on the
one hand on the one hand Nancy Pelosi
wants the enthusiasm that comes along
with this young socialist base on the
other hand she doesn't want them taking
control the party so how do you train
the 16 year old to take the wheel if you
don't actually have a set of backup
brakes in the passenger side of the seat
Nancy Pelosi is trying to grab that
wheel and the Democrats are shrugging
her off the newfangled Democrats are
shrugging her off the same way they're
shrugging off Joe Biden here is Nancy
Pelosi though trying to downplay AOC is
important saying listen anybody who is a
Democrat in that district wins well we
won this election it wasn't in districts
like mine or Alexandria's however wonder
and she's a wonderful member of Congress
I think all of our colleagues
test but those are districts that are
solidly Democratic this glass of water
would win with a D next to it in those
districts and not to not to diminish the
the exuberance and the personality and
the rest of Alexandria and the other
members
okay yes to diminish them Hey she's
saying I want the exuberance I don't
want their thinking so I think a door
knock that would be great she's right by
the way anybody who's a Democrat wins in
that district I've been saying this for
a long time this idea that she is the
leader of the new fangled Democrats
because she won in a heavily blue
district after winning 15,000 votes in a
primary is patently insane there are a
bunch of Democrats who are in purple
States or in red districts who have to
battle for their political lives this is
somewhat like saying that the new wave
of the Republican Party is whoever is
the rightmost member of the Republican
Party even if there are a bunch of
Republicans in purple states in Ohio in
Florida who still have to win their
districts parties happen to be diverse
because different areas of the country
are diverse but the media are treating
aoc with kid gloves and not only kid
gloves they are pushing her their
brilliant by the way so is Pelosi Pelosi
still stood on the cover of Rolling
Stone
with Ilhan Omar and AOC I think the
Nancy Pelosi is trying to feed the
alligator a little bit of the time
hoping that the alligator eats her last
it ain't gonna eat her last it's gonna
eat her first there's a receipt there's
a reason that Rashida Talib came out
yesterday and suggested that the
leadership of the Democratic Party was
racist these kids as Nancy Pelosi might
put it are not going to sit in the car
in the back of the car for very long
they're going to try to take control of
the car they are doing that right now
and they don't know anything
Nancy Pelosi knows this Chuck Schumer
knows this everybody who watches
politics knows this the people the aoc
wing of the party is ignorant as all
hell here's an example of this so AOC
yesterday so fresh so face she was
appearing on Yahoo News and she
suggested that America should cut aid to
Israel because Benjamin Netanyahu the
elected Prime Minister of Israel five
times over who's made territorial
concessions including the Wye River
Accords in the past who unilaterally
undertook a 10 month ceasefire with
Hamas and the settlement stopped a
settlement freeze in 2007-2008 now this
this dolt
AOC is suggesting
and America should cut aid to Israel
because of Netanyahu now if you want to
argue then America should cut foreign
aid generally that's an argument that I
think is there but if you want to argue
that America should continue giving aid
to countries like Egypt and Saudi Arabia
that America should continue giving
foreign aid to countries that are ruled
by dictators but should cut aid to
Israel because you don't like Bibi
Netanyahu you're just a dolt I think
what we're really seeing is the a sense
of authoritarianism across the world I
think that Netanyahu is a trump-like
figure I think that we you know there
are so many ways to approach this issue
I would hope and wish that a diplomatic
approach could could change some an
impact policy doesn't all have to be
legislative but what would you would you
be in favor of reducing military or
economic aid to Israel I mean I think
it's on the table I think it's not
certainly on the table and I think it's
something that that can be discussed a
trump-like figure okay Bibi Netanyahu
who served in the Special Forces went to
MIT served as foreign minister served as
prime minister has a long political
history is one of the smartest men in
politics like he is not a trump-like
figure they said this is absurd it's
absurd but these are the dholtze that
the Democratic Party has decided must be
treated with kid gloves and then they're
surprised when those people try to take
control the bus
good luck with dad okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today
obviously the burning of Notre Dom is
the forefront of everybody's mind the
best movie about Notre Dom the best book
about notre Thomas obviously The
Hunchback of Notre nom by Victor Hugo
which is a great book there is yet to be
a movie of Hunchback of Notre Dom that
actually finishes the finishes the book
the way the book finishes the book is
extraordinarily dark I mean incredibly
incredibly dark no movie could end that
way they all usually change the endings
that it's a happy ending but the best
version of the Hunchback of Notre Dom is
the original 1939 version with Charles
Laughton as the Hunchback and ceedric
Hardwick as the as the priest and
Maureen O'Hara as Esmerelda it's really
a terrific film I it really does hold up
and stands the test of time huge budget
film also from the best year in the
history of movies 1939 here's a little
bit of the preview
[Music]
okay the movie itself it's really good
Lawton is terrific
Lawton is one of the great actors of
this time period in film the music is
great it's just it's really rich if it
were in color and seed Ricardo could
straighten though the whole movie is
really really good so go check out the
original Hunchback of Notre time also
was the first movie for Marine O'Hara
who is a beautiful woman back in the day
so go as I say really good movie was
nominated for Best Picture did not win
but worthy of a watch for sure okay time
for some things that I hate okay so
there's a story out of Arizona that is
just devastating apparently according to
Arizona central.com immigration
officials last week deported the spouse
of the US soldier killed in Afghanistan
in 2010 leaving the couple's 12-year old
daughter in Phoenix then abruptly
reverses decision on Monday when the
deported man was allowed to return to
the United States Jose Gonzalez Carranza
thirty was arrested by immigration and
customs enforcement officers last Monday
on the way to his welding job and then
deported to Nogales Sonora early
Thursday morning
according to Gonzalez Carranza and his
attorney
Isaac Ezekiel Hernandez in Dallas
Carranza was married to armed Army
private first class Barbara Vieira who
was killed on September 18th 2010 while
serving in the US Army in Afghanistan
she was 22
apparently Gonzales Carranza told the
Republic the Arizona Republic he's
allowed to re-enter the United States
through the D conscience II port of
entry in Nogales Arizona on Monday
afternoon he said he was then driven
back to Phoenix where ice officials
dropped him off at the agency's
headquarters near downtown ice officials
offered no explanation for the decision
to allow him to return to the US
Hernandez believes the reversal was
triggered by media attention the
deportation received in Dallas Carrera
said he was eager to see his daughter
who lives with our grandparents we
obviously have to be careful in how we
handle illegal immigrants in the United
States illegally this particular case is
obviously ridiculous so bad that the
Immigration and Customs Enforcement had
traverse it says wife was killed in
Afghanistan and then he was deported
leaving his daughter alone in Arizona I
think it is fair to say that we should
be looking at giving citizenship to
people whose spouses died in the line of
duty in the military does that seem fair
and this this would be a good place to
start to change the law if the law does
not already state that
other two other things that I hate so
MSNBC's Andrea Mitchell is already going
after Peabody judge and this this should
be amusing the Democratic walk left is
saying that Buddha judge is not
intersectional enough so she says well
maybe the reason Buddha judge is is
rising in the polls is because he is
less threatening a gay white man is less
threatening than a woman of color there
are a number of women who have not been
getting very much traction have been
overlooked shall we say Klobuchar
Gillibrand even Carla Harris with her
very big rollout has not been getting as
much attention as Pete Buddha judge is
it is it possible that you know a
married gay white man from South Bend
Indiana is less threatening to to some
of the voters than a woman I think we're
a woman of color I think that's one
thing that Democrats some Democrats are
believing okay well this is amazing if
the Democrats turn the attack into Budaj
edge into he's not intersectional enough
because he's just a gay guy as opposed
to a woman of color
it'll be amusing to watch the Democrats
tear each other apart over this whole
thing the real reason that booty
gestures riding and rising in the polls
is because Buddha says comes off well
because he is a articulate guy who
happens to have a sterling intellectual
background and also more importantly
because he comes off as a moderate he's
running as a moderate now he is not a
moderate his policies are not moderate
every policy that Bernie Sanders
espouses Buddha judge basically follows
but I don't know that that's actually
going to to change anything for for
Buddha judge at the moment he's going to
continue to be portrayed as the
optimistic moderate in the same way that
John Edwards was in 2004 I don't think
he has a pathway to the nomination but I
do think that it is very likely he's
selected his VP candidate on anybody's
ticket given his early riser okay we'll
be back here a little bit later today
with two additional hours lots of guests
today you're gonna want to stop by got
Bishop Baron showing up to talk about
Notre Dame and Cathedral we've got
Daniel Hannan who is stopping by we got
Dennis Miller stopping by so you're
definitely gonna want to be part of the
show today go check it out over at daily
wear comm subscribe we always appreciate
it and we'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
the facade of notre-dame remains but the
heart of the 800 year old cathedral has
been turned to ash is there any more
fitting metaphor for Western
civilization we will analyze appearance
versus reality from Paris to the 2020
primaries check it out at daily wire
calm